- Hi, I'm here with Samm Levine.
I'm an Emotional
Fluffer, so as you know,
as soon as you walked in that
door, you're up for grabs.
So you can be roasted
at any moment in time.
- Oh my goodness. I didn't
know Emotional Fluffer
was a job title.
I've been filling our my
Unemployment records all wrong.
- Yeah, well, I get paid.
So I'm technically employed.
- Fair enough.
(upbeat music)
- If you were to be roasted
do you have anything
that you'd be afraid of,
people would say to you?
- My lisp. My lisp.
It just comes out
when I talk about it.
So please don't talk about it.
- It's a pretty strong lisp.
- Yes, thank you so much.
- But you mask it well.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
- Last time they like called
me, they said I have a
flat ass, which is true.
Like, come at me.
Anything you could ever
say about me, I've already
thought about myself.
- That's exactly, yeah.
- And I'm excited, honestly.
I'm like, did Martha
Stewart google me?
Like, she had to
like, maybe google.
I'm like so flattered.
- I'm pretty thick skinned.
I don't embarrassed that easily.
I wrote on the roast, so.
- So you're already
so talented you just,
nothing affects you?
- I just..
- Ooohh yeah, she got you.
- If you were getting roasted,
what would you be afraid
that people would
make fun of you for?
- Any YouTube comment that
has called me a fat *****.
- Okay, I'm afraid
that people are gonna
all me a fat *****.
- Ooooooooo, well,
you're looking great.
- Thank you. You too, darling.
Thank you.
- I have to say you are
the least threatening man,
and as a man in
Hollywood right now,
that is the nicest
thing I could say.
- Oh, thanks. (laughs)
- I'm an Emotional Fluffer
so my job is to get you hard.
- Alright.
- So when you get up there..
- Okay.
- You're just ready to go.
- I'm ready.
- I mean, smoking hot.
- Well, thanks.
- You look..
- I'm one of the few who
tied his own tie, by the way.
Check the others, clip-on.
- Truly, I want you to
be my dad and my daddy.
- Alright.
- You know what I mean?
- I think I do.
- I'm gonna get you, getting
you ready to be roasted.
Dulce, you're so fine.
You sound like a candy.
You should be Godiva because
I wanna go god-diving
in your panty drawer.
- Ooooooooooo, girl
that was so sweet.
- Okay.
_ It's been a long
time for your girl.
- More like Adam
Lusting for that dick.
- Oooohhhhh, flattered.
I'm flattered. Oooohhhh!
- Your Rogaine's
worst nightmare, baby.
- You are so sweet
to your guests.
- Yes, I think I be probably
the only guy up there
probably get roasted the
most, besides Bruce Willis.
- And I know you're
known for your rebounds,
and I would love to
rebound with you.
You know what I mean?
I'm gonna be thinking about you.
I'm gonna be.
- You say you're wide open.
Double your 4, baby.
White females only.
- (laughs) Okay. Alright.